all right before we get started yes this
is a spoiler free review because there's
a lot to unpack in this game and some of
its spoiler territory so spoiler free
review here Bri these explore wheeler
video will come on Monday Monday morning
ish so be here for that but for now
sporting the free review for Final
Fantasy 7 remake let's do it
[Music]
Final Fantasy 7 remake so the Final
Fantasy 7 remake is a remake of Final
Fantasy sevens Midgar segment which is
funny because that was like a five hour
segment from an RPG in the 90s that
clocked in at around 35 hours when I
first beat it 40 what I just did
recently I don't know how I did it
faster when I was younger but I did I
was scratching my head as to whether or
not they could make this work and for
the most part they actually do cuz if
you look at the Midgar segment and Final
Fantasy 7 it does have all of the
elements present to make a compelling
story that feels like a movie in and of
itself for at least a season of
television character introductions
there's conflict there's growth there's
tragedy so the potential is there to
make a full game that works for the most
part this game does work first of all I
mean yeah this is nostalgia coming at me
so I'm gonna get the nostalgia out of
the way it was amazing seeing these
characters and this story come to life
in the fashion that it does here this is
Final Fantasy 7 this is a very important
RPG for the RPG genre in general and a
lot of fans out there one is if there is
a Final Fantasy to get this remade
overhaul treatment it is definitely
Final Fantasy 6 and also 7 and as I was
playing this I kind of saw it as season
1 of a Final Fantasy 7 show if they
would ever do a show like if they ever
did a Final Fantasy 7 Series season 1
would definitely just be the Midgar
second so when that kind of clicked with
me I was like okay so this is like a
Final Fantasy 7 show that looks better
than a show would because a show would
not have the budget to feel as alive as
it does in this game so I just feel like
this is the optimal way of doing the
story justice in modern day so they did
the story justice in that scale they did
the characters justice everything right
down to alright cloud so who is it era
35 the answer is clearly Jesse now but
the answers Tifa well most of the time
anyway point is go cloud but it being a
remake alright there's a new battle
system now it's not just turn-based
battle system you hack slash and dodge
to build up your ATB meter then when
your meter is properly built up you can
use spells and abilities you can't roll
one character at a time but you just
click right over to another character
and now you're controlling them bonus I
don't know if the turn-based RPG
elements the correct terminology but at
the very least the tactical element that
one would expect from an RPG and the
action RPG elements mixed together in
battle in a way that's much better than
I thought it was going to at first it
seems like a lot you have to multitask
multitasking is
my cup I'm not good at it but you will
get good at it you'll get better at it
when you run into those moments where
you're like oh that's
come on you will get to the point where
you're building up a meter doing an
ability with cloud before he even starts
pulling the ability off after you've
selected that ability you're already
over to Baron you're lighting up the
enemy as well I mean you just you get
good at it doesn't mean some of the
fights aren't tough doesn't mean some of
the fights aren't cheap is
sometimes I'm just saying the balancing
of materia and abilities that all works
for me in here I mean the materia
systems not new that's legitimately the
magic system from the original Final
Fantasy 7 so I was glad it was the way
they did it in here it wouldn't have
felt like Final Fantasy 7 to me if they
didn't but they don't have all of the
material in the remake that you might be
familiar with from the original Final
Fantasy 7 but they can't they can't have
that they need materia that is conducive
to this play style specifically for the
remake but rest assured it's plentiful
materia that lets you build your
characters how you want to build them
also I like the fact that the summon
materia didn't break the game I mean
summon materia is in this game you do
have summons they're very extravagant
very flashy they look amazing but it's
not like you're ever like I just want to
get over this battle so alright
summon materia let's just get through it
and one hit there dad let's move on
you're never knights of the round in
fact the game doesn't even let you have
the option of using your summoned
materia unless the battle is pretty
tough for you I mean the game's alright
you need a little extra here you go
something but again good support but it
doesn't break the battle you still have
to win with your skill there is a
classic mode but classic mode isn't
classic mode it's just classic mode it's
not like the camera backs up to look
like classic Final Fantasy 7 J RPG
battle structure and then you just take
turns hitting back and forth no classic
modes just like regular mode only the
computer controls all of the characters
including the one you're selected and
they just hit slash and dodge until your
meters up and then when your meter
builds up then you can do spells and
abilities also you can take control of
them anyway the point is I feel like the
computers playing half the game for me
for the battles I would never do that it
would be cool if they do patch it to
where you can do a classic Final Fantasy
7 battle system for classic mode that'd
be sweet granted the game is probably
not balanced to do that but it would be
a mode that I would be interested in
playing at least for a bit but they did
a good job at balancing the characters
and here uniquely cloud was my bruiser
brawler Tifa was a fighter also
half of a mage fighter mage I would say
battle mage kickboxing match ferrets
great at long range also against flying
enemies and Aerith always is your mage
but the game's constructed in such a way
where it's not like you have all four of
them and you have to pick your best
three now the way the story rolls out
you're either cloud and Tifa or cloud
Barret and Tifa
or cloud and Barret now you have the
ones you need for the story you're
playing at the time however the enemies
they have you go up against are really
well balanced against the characters
they make you have now in a world where
battles where you have to balance all
your characters and move between them I
enjoyed doing that for the tactic and
strategy element I did not enjoy having
to do that to get them out of deep
because sometimes the characters you're
not controlling they can be idiots I'm
like to bear it what are you doing you
stay at range why are you in that guy's
face he's gonna district a you did it
you just got hit badly dude you're
embarrassing me in front of the ancients
and the world building I gotta say
before I jump on some of the pacing the
world is amazing I mean we saw this on
PlayStation 1 graphics maybe you saw the
HD remaster which is still the old
polygon the man when you see it in this
glory and you're hanging out in these
seedy back alleys you can almost smell
the smell of popcorn flat beer and weed
like everywhere cuz they did a good job
at creating atmosphere with this game
the atmosphere that fundamentally feels
like Midgar and in that comes the music
the music is amazing everything from the
battle music the Shinra theme you just
it takes you back to a place where
you're like it's cinematic and scope but
also shows you how great the music was
from when it came out it's genius music
was then is now and it's great to hear
these modern renditions of them and as
much as I do say the Midgar segment this
game does work as a full game in and of
itself it's undeniably bloated in parts
I don't know that this game had to be
40-something hours long like side quests
in a game like this side quests are good
people need your help and you want to
help people because nothing's free it
clouds a mercenary and we're all
entrepreneurs at heart come on you got
to make some money however when the side
quests cease to be side quests but
they're rather smaller menial tasks that
you have to do to get to the next big
quest I really can't find a good reason
as to why other than the game just it's
trying to be longer than it probably
needs a debate if you're sure not all
the side quests are that way at a point
the games like okay
so now you know about side quests so now
we're not gonna make you do the side
quests you should though but for a time
in this game I just felt like they were
puffing up the runtime with side quest
I'm all for a nice solid amount of
gameplay hours I don't want the game to
feel like it's dragging his feet with me
on quite a few occasions I was like it
just seems like the game makers just sat
in a room and they were like all right
for every scenario let's try to make it
as long as humanly possible to get out
of that scenario the more wrenches you
can throw into the gears the more
obstacles you can throw in their path
the better that's one down only two more
lights to go where should be a
five-minute task that's where we're
gonna bump it up to about 40 and yeah I
wrestled with the fact that it might be
because I know how short this task is
supposed to be because I played it on
the PlayStation but in a world where
clouds walking with Aerith and they
should have been a pretty quick a to be
kind of trip and instead you're
scrambling on the rooftops as the game
drags its feet like dude I feel like the
game is making me go around my elbow to
get to my ass just a general annoyance
really but if you're gonna do that you
have to fool me into thinking it's
necessary to do that and it just it kind
of became an internalized joke in my own
head and every scenario I was like okay
how are they gonna make this longer than
it needs to be sure enough they would
every time it's Goldilocks and the three
bears that's what I feel like I'm in
right now to paddock not padded enough
just right however the game's still
enjoyable it is the thing I need to
bring up because what give my thoughts
those are thoughts I will say also this
game is accessible for the most part for
people who haven't played Final Fantasy
7 before like if this is your first I've
never played Final Fantasy 7 I want to
pick this game up do it and for the most
part you'll be like holy is this
has this been the story people have been
raving about for decades and for the
most part yes it is but there are a
couple moments where the game seems to
operate as though you've played Final
Fantasy 7 before some of those moments
are just Easter eggs they're just nice
extras to know but there are a couple
parts I was like if you don't know Final
Fantasy 7 these little flashes are gonna
feel like look what are they feel like
some people might feel lost but it's
hard for me to see this through eyes
that hasn't haven't played Final Fantasy
7 so in the end I really enjoyed the
Final Fantasy 7 remake it's a love
letter to Final Fantasy 7 at least the
first few hours but it's um
to not just see it experience it to the
scope and scale in which you experience
it in here is a great introduction to
the characteristic Shinra corporation I
thought the battle mechanics were a lot
of fun there are other things I have
thoughts about that I just can't talk
about here and I know this probably
frustrating for you I want to hear all
of your thoughts but I can't give all of
my thoughts here but there are things in
spoiler territory that I definitely do
have thoughts about but when people ask
me is it worth it yes absolutely it was
worth it for me I had a great time
playing this game it was worth me buying
at full price all right so that's for
the spoiler free segment I actually have
more thoughts about the spoiler field
stuff to be honest with you but I'll
elaborate this Monday and my Final
Fantasy 7 remake spoiler talk be there
for that in the meantime the Final
Fantasy 7 remake have you played it what
did you think about it or what do you
think about the original Final Fantasy 7
in general or what's your favorite final
fantasy of all time whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more the
clouds over their life you have 13 hours
in which to solve the labyrinth before
your baby brother becomes one of us for